welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and with multiverse of madness fast
approaching with elizabeth olsen scarlet
witch playing a monumental role in this
dark chapter of the mcu we here at new
rockstars thought it was a good time to
revisit the darkest chapter of the mcu
the darkhold first seen in the hands of
harkness in one of the darkest cinematic
chapters of the mcu wan division in
particular this page on the right that
supposedly details the dark doom for the
mcu through wanda maximoff's
transformation into the scarlet witch
and since the newest multiverse of
madness trailer seems to directly
mention this darkhold page specifically
with this scarlet witch inspired altar
behind a leaping america chavez i think
it's well past time to take another dive
as to what this foreboding scarlet witch
symbol means in the mcu's dark book of
the damned and what it could possibly
mean for the mcu as a whole so let's go
ahead and take a look at what's in this
book by reading rainbow nerd babies okay
so this dark hold page on the right here
is clearly depicting a crowned female
figure very much implied to be the
scarlet witch as this crown figure's
body is positioned very much like the
scarlet witch was during wanda's
prophetic vision of her future self when
she was first exposed to the mind stone
of loki's scepter by hydra but what
people don't really want to talk about
is what is behind this image of the
scarlet witch because this my beautiful
nerd babies to me seems exactly what the
wicked witch of the best agatha harkness
was reading to wanda in one division the
scarlet witch is not born she is forged
she has no coven no need for incantation
now the most important thing that agatha
mentions here is that the scarlet witch
is not born she is forged that right
there is what i believe that this page
is talking about and the reason why i
think this is because this weird like
shape or image behind this dark hole
scarlet witch is the super popular piece
of sacred geometry called metatron's
cube now if you don't already know
sacred geometry is the spiritual study
of how the entire universe from
microscopic to galactic scales seems to
follow a secret law of physical shapes
and patterns you know like for example
how the spiraling nature of sunflowers
and nautilus molex imitate the golden
ratio of fibonacci and how this golden
ratio seems to form the cornerstone of
many famous designs throughout history
like da vinci's mona lisa and the
pyramids of giza hell even the human
face imitates the golden ratio which is
kind of wild so basically the study of
sacred geometry is essentially the study
of the source code shapes that make up
the blueprint of all creation and in
judaic text the figure metatron was
actually an angel from evan specifically
in charge of monitoring the flow of
cosmic energies from the divine god into
the mortal universe of man with this
symbol of metatron's cube being the
physical representation of the very
building blocks of the universe the
universe's matrix code if you will and
with the scarlet witch's cosmic role as
a reality altering being of potentially
apocalyptic proportions this comparison
is completely appropriate as the scarlet
witch is essentially the mcu's metatron
and this is because within this strange
multi-line design of metatron's cube can
be found all five fundamental shapes
that have been observed to make up our
reality according to the tenets of
sacred geometry and these shapes are
known as the five platonic solids after
the famous greek philosopher plato who
was very much into these types of
patterns in nature as well and these
shapes are the star tetrahedron which
represents the element of fire the
hexahedron for the element of earth
which is basically just a cube the
octahedron for the element of air the
icosahedron for water and most
importantly for this video the
dodecahedron for the element of the
ether which the philosopher plato
regarded as the element that is used for
arranging the constellations of the
whole heavens and a symbol that we can
see within the very pages of asgard's
own chronicles of the very birth of
creation when odin tells thor and jane
the story of the dark chaos of the ether
the leader malekith made a weapon out of
that darkness and it was called the
ether while the other relics often
appear as stones the ether is fluid and
ever-changing it changes matter into
dark matter so this all being said the
platonic solids of metatron's cube are
super significant in this dark cold page
here because much like the platonic
solids represent core aspects of our
reality in real life scarlet witch's
metatron's cube in the dark hole appears
to represent the six infinity energies
of the mcu in particular with the use of
the circles surrounding the cube's
perimeter because in metatron's cube
there's a total of six circles but
specifically this darkhold page is
telling how one day the scarlet witch
will be able to affect every single
aspect of reality like some type of hot
living european infinity gauntlet
because while four of the circles
surrounding the scarlet witch's torso in
the dark hold seem to represent the time
power soul and space singularities of
the mcu i'm of the belief that the huge
circle surrounding the scarlet witch's
head and therefore mind is represented
of the mind stone singularity that now
lives inside of wanda after the tragic
events of infinity war when scarlet
witch had to kill the vision by
absorbing the infinity stone energies
with the scarlet witch herself in her
chaotic hair in the dark hold
representing the sixth less predictable
dark element of chaos with this chaotic
hair design even briefly being seen
within the marvel studios logo of the
multiverse of madness trailer this
entire darkhold page is supposed to
symbolize wanda now having the power to
affect all of reality with the specific
combination of red reality stone
energies and yellow mine stone energies
because when agatha harkness says that
the scarlet witch is forged in the one
division finale i believe that agatha is
talking about how wanda maximoff has
been slowly and secretly forged with
cosmic infinity stone energies of the
mcu over time starting of course when
the mind stone itself made the sentient
independent decision to as agatha puts
it amplify a little bit of the latent
chaos magic that already lived inside of
wanda maxima as we saw in the flashbacks
of wanda vision episode viii and hey say
what you will about their actions and
motives but do it quietly but the
inquisitors definitely have a sense of
style and you too can have a great look
with the help of our friends over at
epic hero shop they release all kinds of
merch based on the stuff that we are
excited about like marvel dc and star
wars and they actually just re-released
some of their limited edition shirts
based on the mandalorian and the book of
bubba fat and they also have a really
cool line based on the many looks of
moon knight they have a really dope set
of hoodies with one even having a konshu
head logo and the phrase embrace the
chaos and the other having a cool design
inspired by the mr night look which is a
pretty dope look i can't wait to see
that in action so grab one of each so
you will always have one to reflect on
which side of the force that you're
feeling that day and they have all types
of clever and fun merch inspired by
spiderman no way home loki peacemaker
and all the other properties that we are
obsessed with and sign up for their
newsletter at the bottom of their
website to get notified about merch
drops and check out all of their
incredible products at the
epicheroshop.com be your own hero it was
after this interaction with the mind
stone that wanda was granted full
control of her chaos magic abilities all
thanks to that sneaky sentient mind
stone a sentient infinity stone that
would of course also sneakily create
ultron for the express purpose of having
ultron create a physical body for the
mind stone through the birth of vision
you know the second tony and bruce
stopped being dweeby science nerds for
like two seconds to go talk to some
girls big mistake never go talk to some
girls when there's science to be done
but yeah this mine stone is seemingly
playing some type of cosmic game with
the avengers that thor seemed to pick up
on at the end of age of ultron the mind
stone is the fourth of the infinity
stones to show up in the last few years
it's not a coincidence someone has been
playing an intricate game has made pawns
of us and this of course is extremely
crucial because without ultron creating
the vision wanda would not have been
forced into the next step into her
cosmic infinity stone forgery which is
when she absorbed an absolute [ __ ] ton
of the yellow mine stone energy into her
body no longer making her just the queen
of red chaos energy but also a yellow
mine stone energy manipulator giving her
the vital infinity stone ingredient that
she needed to be able to manipulate and
rewrite all of west view on a molecular
level and resurrect a vision who was
tucked away inside of her b because
again vision is pretty much nothing but
the mind stone inside a vibranium
housing so when the scarlet witch
absorbed all that mind stone energy at
the end of infinity war she saved vision
inside of her body along with all that
mind stone energy that is now a part of
her as far as i can see in the mcu the
yellow milestone singularity appears to
be both capable of being a
self-sustaining electrical power source
for the vision as well as an insanely
powerful infinite stone singularity of
atomic mastery with both vision and
electro being able to phase through and
manipulate solid matter through the
manipulation of electrons which leads me
to believe that the mind stone is truly
the infinity singularity of all atoms in
molecules and matter in the mcu which is
in direct contrast to wanda maximoff's
red chaos magic of darkness which
appears to turn regular matter like say
wanda's hands in the wanda vision finale
into dark matter much like odin
described the red reality stone
singularity was capable of doing in this
scene in thor 2. it changes matter into
dark matter it seeks out host bodies
drawing strength from their life force
because if chaos magic can turn matter
into dark matter that's basically just a
pencil eraser that erases matter but
once wanda maximoff got the metaphorical
pencil lead of the mind stone her mind
can now draw reality as she saw fit on
the mind stone's atomic level and this
would explain why wanda was now able to
rewrite the molecular makeup of westview
monica rambo's clothes and even monica
rambo herself it was due to wanda using
her mind stone magic to repurpose how
matter is organized so to wrap it all up
scarlet witch's entry in the darkhold is
basically just telling us of the true
scary potential of wanda maximoff as a
type of living nexus of infinity stone
energy especially now that she's been
crowned by the cosmos at the end of
wanda vision just like an infinity
gauntlet a hot european infinity
gauntlet but that is what i believe that
this darkhold page has been trying to
tell us since wanovision last year but
let us know what you guys think in the
comment section below my beautiful nerd
babies you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some really weird [ __ ] you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
social media and don't forget to hit up
newrockstarsmerch.com we got really cool
moonlight hoodies by the way so check
those out thank you guys so much for
spending time with me i love you guys so
much and i'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you